Hey everyone, this is Ryan here, and welcome back to our Peridontic series.
This video is going to be about surgical therapy in periodontics.
So I apologize in advance as it's going to be a really long video, but it's a really
interesting topic, so I hope we can have a lot of fun learning about it.
So local therapy is designed to remove bacterial plaque and local factors that favor its accumulation.
Now we already talked about non-surgical therapy, and when that's not enough to resolve the
disease, often surgical therapy is then considered.
Since we're talking about surgical therapy, we need to talk about gingival flap design.
So gingival flaps are used for better access and visibility to the area of concern.
So I'm going to go through each of these concepts, and they're all important to know for the
board exam, and I'll go through them one at a time so we can really understand the concept
behind them.
So the first one is that the base of the flap should be wider than the top of the flap to
ensure adequate blood supply.
So in this first image here, that idea is illustrated.
You can see the top of the flap is up here, and since it was flapped up, this area was
by the teeth, you can tell that the scalloping matches where the gingival margins were, and
the base of the flap is still in contact with the bone.
So you can notice the base of the flap is wider than the top, and this ensures that the minimal
amount of vasculature is severed, and the top of the flap can remain well vascularized
and vital after surgery.
Here's an example where the base is narrower than the top, and that's not good because we're
severing some vasculature here and here that could supply the top corners, and you can get
tissue necrosis, just not a good result.
The next concept is that incisions should occur over intact bone, not over bony defects
or eminences.
So you want to avoid vertical incisions over bony prominences, like by the canines, the
uniform ridge, lingual of the mandible, and you also want to avoid areas of bony defects.
So we can see this second image illustrating that idea.
These incisions are on a nice sound intact bone.
You can notice this area of recession, a big bony defect here, and this is not a good flap
because the vertical incision is right by that defect.
Say for example, we had to surgically extract that tooth, you certainly want the flap margin
to be at least one or two teeth over from the area you're working on.
You want the corners of the flap to be rounded, not sharp, vertical releases, these vertical
incisions should occur at the line angles of their respective teeth.
So that's where the third image comes in, and you can also appreciate this in the previous
two, but the ideal area for the margin of the flap to contact the tooth is going to
be right at the line angle.
That's because if you did it in the middle of the papilla, you'd cause loss of that papilla,
and you'd have the formation of what are known as black triangles.
If the edge of the flap came into the mid-facial surface of the tooth, then that often would
cause noticeable gingival recession.
So you don't want to be mid-facial, you don't want to be mid-papilla, you want to be in-between
the two and right at the line angle.
So line one here illustrates being mid-papilla, line two here illustrates being mid-facial.
So you also want to avoid vital structures, you should be careful high up in the labial
maxilla, in the infra-orbital region, and in the lingual mandible, where you have thin
tissue, where the lingual artery is, so you want to avoid vital structures like that.
And like I've talked about in previous videos, it's really important what the patient is doing
at home to take care of their teeth, just as important as what you're doing in the clinic.
If not more important.
So like that, post-operative flat control is the most important procedure after periodontal
surgery.
So the next thing we have to talk about for flaps, we talked about flap design, now let's
talk about the two different types in terms of thickness.
So we have the split or partial thickness flap or mucosal flap, I included all the names
here just to be thorough.
And the full thickness are mucoperiosteal flap.
So this name is helpful to include because it clues you in to the actual layers that
are included in the flap.
So for the mucosal one, we have the gingiva or the mucosa and the submucosa.
So whether your gingiva or mucosa depends on where you are relative to the muco gingival
junction.
So both of these include the epithelium and the laminopropia and the submucosa has the
vessels and the underlying nerves, things like that.
So this type of flap is a little less aggressive and it's used for muco gingival surgery because
we don't need to expose the bone, that would be unnecessary.
The full thickness flap is called mucoperiosteal because it includes the periostium.
So the periostium is that thin, really dense, connective tissue layer that directly contacts
and covers bone.
So we have to remove that and include that as part of the flap when we need to contact
when we need to work on the actual bone.
So it's used for osteosurgery and periodontal regeneration to permit primary closure as
well as in apically repositioned flaps.
We'll talk about all that later on in the video, but I will say primary closure when
I say that I'm talking about the edges of the soft tissue when sutured back together,
touch each other.
In other words, there's no open wound left, that would be secondary closure.
So whenever alveolar bone is exposed, like in the full thickness flaps, expect about one
millimeter of bone resorption and remodeling.
This is sort of a natural body response and should expect some amount of resorption anytime
bone is exposed to the oral cavity.
So talked about flap design and now we talked about the two different types of partial thickness
and full thickness flaps.
Papilla preservation is a concept that I've sort of already talked about.
We talked about how we don't want to split the papilla, that was sort of the conventional
flap design was have the margins go straight through the papilla, but then we were getting
this papilla loss and formation of black triangles.
So the papilla preservation flap is to preserve the papilla.
So now this is sort of different from what we're talking about here.
These are wider flaps to expose a large area of bone.
These are smaller incisions if we just wanted to work on a smaller localized area, but you
can see the concept is the same.
The edges of the flap contact the line angles of the teeth.
So the three types of papilla preservation flaps are detailed in these three lines.
This one goes from the lingual line angle of this tooth to the facial line angle of this
tooth.
This one's scalloped from lingual line angle to lingual line angle.
This one's scalloped from facial line angle to facial line angle.
So those are papilla preservation flaps.
So let's talk a little bit more about the full thickness flap.
Since we're involving the periosteum layer, there are some specific incisions that we need
to know when doing this type of flap.
So the first one is the internal or reverse bevel incision, and that's shown as one in
this image, and it's about one millimeter from the gingival margin, the crest of the
gingiva.
So you can see it's a little bit apart from that.
It's beveled, it's not straight up and down, straight side to side, and it's used to remove
the pocket lining, yet conserve the outer gingiva.
The circular or curvicular incision shown as number two here is right through the base
of the pocket to the alveolar crest.
So you can imagine like sticking a periodontal probe into a pocket instead of now we're taking
a scalpel and cutting through the pocket to the bone.
And number three here is the interdental or interproximal incision.
And that's to remove the collar of tissue around the tooth you created with the first
two incisions.
So you can see number one contacts this area of bone, number two contacts this area of bone,
and so there's this little piece of soft tissue that's still connected to bone that we're
just going to slice off with that last third incision.
So the combination of all three of those incisions is what we could call a modified
Whitman flap.
It involves those three incisions and provides access to sub-gensurable areas for debridement,
for cleaning.
If there's calculus there for say we couldn't get with a conventional scaling and replaning.
And with the goal of new attachment.
Now we also have an apically repositioned flap which requires the addition of vertical
releasing incisions.
Note that all three of these were horizontal and involved the top of the flap here.
And now we're adding in these two vertical slices so that we can, and you want to make
sure they're beyond the mucogen jivel junction and so then you can safely, you can safely
get underneath the jingiva and the mucosa here, flap this area up, and you can position
the flap so that the top of the flap doesn't come up to where it was here.
It actually, you position it so it's a little bit apical to where it was originally.
And that's in order to attain pocket reduction.
By moving, physically moving the jingiva margin apically.
So the peridontal pack is a device that's sometimes used after this sort of invasive
flap surgery.
Usually consists of ZOE which is zinc oxide eugenol.
And you might recognize this if you watched my endodontics videos it's also the main ingredient
in gut-apertia and endodontic sealer.
They leave it in place typically for one week and they're placed to protect the surgical
wound, minimize discomfort, maintain tissue placement, and help prevent post-op bleeding.
The important thing to know for the board exam is that packs do not enhance healing.
You can think of the zinc oxide eugenol as having sort of a soothing quality so it doesn't
enhance healing but it does protect these things.
So you'd think it would enhance healing but it actually doesn't so that's an important
distinction to know for the board exam.
Little bit counterintuitive.
Alright, so the first category of surgery is gingival surgery.
So this is surgery only involving the jingiva, only soft tissue above the mucogenible junction.
There are two types of gingival surgery.
It's gingivectomy which is excision of gingiva to eliminate superboni pockets or gingival
enlargements say drug-induced gingival enlargement from a calcium channel blocker.
Gingivalplasty is excision of gingiva, sound similar, to reshape tissue deformities.
So you might be thinking what the heck is the difference between the two of those?
They sound awfully similar.
Now the difference between the two is the treatment objective.
So the ectomy is more aggressive and against to eliminate pockets or enlargements.
And the plasti is just some aesthetic reshaping.
It's more for the aesthetics, less aggressive re-contouring.
So it's the way that it's used and the objective that you're trying to achieve is where you
would distinguish between the two terms.
That's how I think of it anyway.
Healing by this type of surgery is by secondary intention only because there is no tissue
to approximate.
So I mentioned primary closure before, closure and intention, same thing.
Primary closure where the wound edges are approximated, they touch each other.
The secondary closure or intention is where they do not.
So you have an open wound.
And this makes sense because if you're just cutting ginger butt off, there's nothing you
can reattach, suture together, you're going to have some amount of open wound there.
A specific type of gingival surgery is distal wedge surgery.
This is for pocket reduction distal to terminal molars.
Depending if you're in the upper arch or lower arch, this looks different.
So for the maxillary terminal molar, you do a full thickness flap, so you're including
periosteum in that, with parallel incisions.
So the two incisions here are parallel to each other.
For mandibular, again, full thickness flap, including periosteum, with a V-shaped incisions.
So you can see that in this.
So I love these two images because they clearly denote the two different types of incisions
used, and believe it or not, this is definitely important to know for the board exam.
It's a little bit of a niche surgery, but it's certainly important to know.
All right.
The second category of surgery that we're going to talk about is mucogengival surgery.
So now we're including both the gingiva and the mucosa, all the soft tissue above and
below the mucogengival junction.
So I don't know if I can overemphasize how important this is to know.
Knowing the free gingiva graft and the connective tissue graft is going to get you so many questions
and it's just so great to know it.
It really cleared everything up for my head when I was in dental school.
So the free gingiva graft is, well, let me just say, these are the two main types of
soft tissue grafts, and definitely, again, commit this to memory, and I hope I can explain
it to you so you really understand the concepts here.
So caratinized tissue, as we talked about in the very first video in this series, includes
both the free gingiva and the attached gingiva.
And of these two, the attached gingiva is the most ideal tissue type, but both of these
are preferable to the non-caratinized alveolar mucosa, and that's because this caratin layer
is a lot stronger.
The whole purpose of this graft, the free gingiva graft, is that we really want caratinized
tissue to surround not only natural teeth, but also crowns and implants because it's
stronger.
Proper and less easy to irritate on tooth brushing because of the caratin layer.
So in this example here, we have a lot of soft tissue recession around an implant here
and you can see this darker mucosa.
The lighter areas are caratinized, that's because the caratin makes it look whiter, and
this area, we have mucosa right up against the implant.
And so that's going to get really irritated if the patient's trying to brush there.
It's not as resistant to the irritation as the caratinized layer is.
So the free gingiva graft is to widen the band of caratinized tissue.
So what we would do, if I can get the pen out, is we would want to perform a free gingiva
graft in this area here, and that could be a valid treatment option for the patient to
promote the growth of caratinized tissue there where there's only alveolar mucosa there now.
In contrast, the connective tissue graft involves taking a layer of connective tissue, usually
from the palate and sutured, over an exposed root surface.
So let's say this tooth right here has a lot of recession, and we could place a connective
tissue graft over this area of exposed root in order to promote the coverage of that root.
So say that patient was really sensitive in that area where there was exposed dentin,
and the connective tissue graft could be a great treatment option for that patient.
So what you do, again, is take this connective tissue from the palate, you'd suture it over
the exposed root surface, usually create a coronaly advanced flap to move the already
existing, the ideal caratinized tissue layer up and over this new graft.
And so this type of graft is to cover the exposed root surface.
So there's a big difference between the two.
They may seem slightly similar, and they are, but in a very simplified but helpful way of
differentiating the two.
The free gingival graft happens below or apical to the gingival margin, and the connective
tissue graft happens above or coronal to the gingival margin.
So one is to widen the band of caratinized tissue, and the other one is for root coverage.
So knowing and distinguishing between these two grafts is super, super important, and
I promise will really, really help.
The last three things to mention here for mucogen gingival surgery, we can do a phrenectomy,
which is a complete removal of the phrenom, phrenotomy is just an incision of the phrenom,
not a complete removal.
So again, we see theectomy being the more aggressive form of surgery, and we'll see that
again in the future, and vestibule plastic, where you make an incision in the base of
the vestibule in order to deepen it.
All right, and this is sort of a review of what we just talked about if you want to go
over it in writing.
So this includes some measurements, and if you're interested, why it's called a free gingival
graft, free by definition, a free graft by definition is transplanted without a nourishing
blood supply.
So it must undergo revascularization from the recipient bed that's receiving that graft.
So the free gingival graft is only the epithelium layer, it lacks a blood supply.
So when you perform a split thickness flap, you expose the vascular bed at the recipient
site so that I can feed and nourish the new caratinized tissue.
And connective tissue graft, same sort of thing, this is just a review about what we
talked about, and I briefly mentioned this, but the palate is the most common donor site
for both of these, for both the free gingival graft and the connective tissue graft.
So definitely remember that the palate is the most often used site for this sort of surgery.
All right, so the third category of surgery is osteosurgery.
So now we're no longer talking about soft tissue, now we're talking about the bone.
And just like anything, before we do any treatment, we want to observe and analyze what's there
to start with.
So let's talk about bone architecture and what this concept refers to.
So visualization of bony architecture allows the clinician to determine the types of bony
defects that are present and the extent of those defects.
Positive architecture means that the interproximal bone is coronal to radicular bone, and that's
what we see in image A.
So the interproximal bone that is between the teeth is higher than the radicular bone, which
is around the root, and that's pretty normal.
Flat architecture is where interproximal and radicular bone are at the same height.
It's flat across.
Negative architecture is where the interproximal bone is apical to the radicular bone, and that's
the opposite of what is normal healthy bone architecture.
So positive architecture is what we want.
So for osteosurgery, we have two different types of surgery.
We have the ostectomy, which is removal of supporting bone, and osteotomy, which is
removal of non-supporting bone.
To remember, gingivectomy was excision of tissue and gingivoplasty was this more conservative
reshaping and recontoring.
So again, theectomy is the more aggressive type, same situation here.
Ostectomy is again removal of supporting alveolar bone, meaning it's directly supporting the
tooth, it's indirect contact with the periodontal ligament.
Theectomy, in contrast, is reduction of bone away from the tooth.
They both aim to create a more physiologic, positive bone architecture, but one does with
removal of supporting bone, and one does not.
So that's the main distinction between those two.
After ostectomy, there's often these peaks of bone remaining at the line angles called
widow's peaks, which predispose to periodontal pockets in these areas, basically saying to
do a thorough job, smooth everything, round everything out.
So you don't have these sharp areas of bone left over, but sometimes you can't help it
and have to go back and do an osteotomy to reshape and recontour that area.
So I also want to briefly tie in an important concept called clinical crown lengthening.
This is where you want to expose more to structure by lowering the bone for several different
purposes, one of which is gaining more feral for crown support, which I have a separate
video on the feral effect and biologic width, so check that out if you want to learn more
about those concepts.
But clinical crown lengthening is essentially combining osteous resection and ostectomy,
lowering the bone with either a gingivectomy by cutting the collar of gingiva away.
And you would do that if there would be at least two millimeters of keratinized tissue
remaining after the gingivectomy, or otherwise, you'd have to do an apically positioned flap,
like I talked about before, physically moving the gingival margin down.
And that would be to conserve the keratinized tissue that is there.
So osteosurgery is used in a whole bunch of areas in dentistry, in periodontics, and in
prosthodontics to get more feral effects.
So you can see how removing some bone, lowering the bone area will also effectively lower where
the gingiva is if you combine it with a gingivectomy or apically positioned flap.
So mechanisms of healing after surgery, there are a couple of different ways that the situation
can go.
You can have regeneration, which is a complete restoration of architecture and function,
or repair, which is not completely restoring architecture and function.
It involves healing by scar or formation of long, junctional epithelium.
So we talked about junctional epithelium, it has a weak hemidesma zone while attachment
to enamel, but it is a sign of healing towards a shallower pocket.
This term long, junctional epithelium is used when a pocket was once very deep, and since
the bone and periodontal ligament have been irreversibly damaged and gone, this had this
physically long pocket that was formed, the soft tissue that comes into its place is a
very physically long, several millimeters long worth of junctional epithelium that attaches
to the tooth, and that's the best we can hope for natural healing.
And so these two terms are formid dichotomy, and these two formid dichotomy as well.
Reattachment is the reunion of epithelial and connective tissue with the tooth root surface
after incision or injury, whereas new attachment is embedding of fresh new PDL fibers into new
cement that has been previously deprived of its original attachment.
So you may be wondering, well, Ryan, you just talked about how bone and PDL were irreversibly
damaged and the best we can hope for is this long, junctional epithelium attached into
the tooth, but how do we get new attachment with new PDL?
Well, wonder no longer.
The last category of surgery is regenerative surgery, and this is where we seek to actually
regenerate tissue that was lost.
So periodontal regeneration, also formerly known as guided tissue regeneration, where
we want to regenerate bone, cementum, and PDL.
Yes, we're going to try to reverse and regenerate bone and PDL and cementum that was lost by
the periodontal disease.
Now this can't be done in every situation.
There's very specific situations and really good patient motivation and oral hygiene to
make this stuff happen, but it is possible in select situations.
So in this treatment, there are three B's that are free-winly used by operators to
have the best chance for successful tissue regeneration.
So I'm a big fan of video games, and there are three classic roles that a group of players
working together would assume to take on a big boss.
So I'm going to diverge for a second here and talk about these three roles.
And I think they'll help you remember these three B's.
So the tank takes the damage from the boss and protects the rest of the players.
The damage focused on dealing damage and defeating the boss, and the healers are responsible
for making sure the other players stay alive.
So I remember the three materials of the regeneration process by assigning each one of these roles
to each one of these materials.
So the barrier membrane is like the tank.
It's placed over the defect and its job is to protect the area.
The bone graft is the damage because it's doing the bulk of the work.
It gets right in there and it's used to regenerate the missing bone.
And the biologic agent is like the healer because it's a medicament that creates a supportive
environment for the rest of the components to do their job.
So I remember the tank, the damage, and the healer as the three B's barrier membrane,
bone graft, and biologic agent.
So a little bit silly, but I think it really helps me remember what each of those things
are doing and let alone what they are.
So why do we need these three components for regeneration?
Well if we did nothing, this is what wound healing would look like.
And these cells populate a wound area during the healing process, listed from fastest to
slowest.
So the epithelial cells and the connective tissue cells would repopulate that wound area
the fastest and the PDL cells labeled four, bone cells labeled three are the two slowest.
So this should make sense because like I was talking about before, the natural healing
process would result in a long junctional epithelium and you'd get all this soft tissue
would grow down into this wound and the bone and PDL wouldn't get a chance to grow up and
restore that attachment that was once there.
So if we do nothing, let the wound heal, often get a long junctional epithelium, which is
a sign of healing, yes, but it's not a complete regeneration that would just be a repair.
So we really want to get a full regeneration when we're talking about periodontal regeneration
or guided tissue regeneration.
So that's why we use those three components.
The barrier membrane would slip in here and that would prevent the downgrowth of the soft
tissue components and we'd place the graft in here to provide a physical scaffolding to
promote new bone formation and we'd also use the biologic agent to help support everything.
So the tank, damage, and the heal.
You can also do direct root surface treatment with chelating agents like EDTA and citric
acid can expose collagen fibrils through de-mineralization and may improve the success
of new attachment.
Alright, so bone graft materials have a lot of definitions associated with them.
So I made them as simple as possible so we can remember them for the board exam.
So the best, well let's talk about these definitions first and then I can go a little bit more
in depth.
So we have four different types of bone graft materials.
There's autographed, which means the bone comes from yourself.
Allograft is from another human, usually a cadaver.
The xenograft is from another animal, usually a cow, and the aloplast is a synthetic or
inorganic.
You can think of like plastic being a synthetic material, just like aloplast is a synthetic
material.
So those are the four main categories of graft materials and there are three main ideas that
grafts can carry out.
So osteoconductive means that the graft is forming a physical scaffold to hold that
area open and provide area for a bone to fill in.
Osteoinductive, I mean it's converting neighboring progenitor cells, these kind of young bone
cells that are nearby into osteoblasts that are going to in turn form bone.
Ogenic means that the bone graft material itself is actually forming new bone.
So the autographed is the best grafting material because it has all three of these qualities.
The autographed is conductive, inductive, and genic.
The allograft is the next best one.
It has the osteoconductive and inductive qualities, but not the genic.
And all of the bone grafts are osteoconductive.
So the xenograft and aloplast are osteoconductive but not the other two.
So listed from first to fourth is sort of the order from best to worst bone graft materials.
So a summary of everything we've talked about.
I know it's a lot, we've talked about the four categories of periodontal surgery, the
gingival, mucogengival, osteous, and regenerative.
And they kind of fit into these two overarching categories of additive where we're trying
to restore tissue, you can do that with regeneration, free gingival graft, connective tissue graft,
and advancing the flap cronally, or we can talk about a subtractive method where we're
trying to bring levels down and reduce pocket depths by doing osteosurgery, reconquering
to get that positive bony architecture, gingivectomy, or apically positioned flap to physically move
the gingival margin down and reduce pocket depths.
And tying it all together, I'm going to leave you with this slide full of beautiful things
to know for the board exam.
These make for really good board exam questions because it ties in the diagnosis classification
stuff we talked about from earlier in the series with the available treatment options
covered in this video.
So for, and this is maybe a bit of an overgeneralization, but definitely a great tool for the board
exam.
So one in two wall defects, you typically would opt to do osteous resection.
Also doing ostectomy to re-contour the bone to restore that ideal, natural, positive architecture.
Whereas if you have three and four wall defects, you would opt to try regeneration.
And that's because the more walls you have, the better blood supply and cell source proximity
you have.
So the deep narrow three wall defect is the ideal, theoretical ideal for regenerating
in for bony defects.
So a deep narrow three wall defect has the most surface area possible of available bone
to populate the graft with bone cells and also to protect the graft while everything
is regenerating.
So think about if you were in a big hurricane, would you rather be in a house with four
walls or a house with one wall?
And so the more walls you have, the more protected the graft is and the more walls there are
to provide new natural bone cells to form new bone in that area.
The same concept with forcations.
So a HAMP class II forcation and either the buckle of an upper molar or either buckle or
lingual of lower molars is ideal for regenerating forcation defects.
Again, the class II provides the deepest narrowest defect with the most available bony walls.
And the Miller class I with a thick gingival biotype, really nice thick gums and a wide
band of kratnized tissue at least two millimeters wide is ideal for regenerating recession defects.
The near, and we talked about this in the first video, but the near 100% chance of success
of root coverage with a connective tissue graft with this type of soft tissue defect.
So to remember, the best types of the ideal defects to restore with their respective treatments
are remember, three for three wall, two for HAMP class II, and one for Miller class I.
So tying it all together is as easy as three, two, and one.
Alright guys, I know that was a lot of material in this video, just go ahead and watch it
a few times and feel free to ask me questions in the comments if anything wasn't clear.
I really hope you enjoyed the video and thanks so much for watching everyone and thanks for
all the support.
I'll see you all in the next video of the periodontic series.